[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de l'actualité à l'assemblée
et au sénat est aujourd'hui avec
brigitte boucher est notre invité est le
député jean christophe lagarde vous êtes
député de seine saint denis et président
de l'ue dit et c'est brigitte qui vous
présente
bonjour jean christophe lagarde vous
êtes député de seine-saint-denis vous
avez soutenu françois bayrou en 2007
avant de rejoindre le nouveau centre et
de fonder en 2012
la force européenne démocrate puis vous
intégrer l'ue dei que vous dirigez
depuis 2014 votre parcours se situe au
centre vous vous êtes à un moment
rapprochée des manuels macron alors que
vous êtes à la tête d'un groupe
d'opposition à l'assemblée nationale
c'est la fin du et en même temps
finalement
vous n'êtes plus macro compatibles
l'alpa le sujet c'est avec qui monsieur
macron est il compatible pour être
compatible avec les gens faut être
capable de les écouter nous nous sommes
une opposition constructive on fait des
propositions depuis le début du mandat
parfois d'ailleurs après les avoir
refusé ils ont été obligé d'y venir
ça aurait été mieux de gagner du temps
et de ne pas faire de contre sens mais
je suis à la fois étonné et déçu d'un
pouvoir dont on croirait la génétique
c'est de penser qu'ils ont toujours
raison c'est d'ailleurs le contraire de
ce qu'il disait pendant l'élection
présidentielle
quand ils sont arrivés soi-disant il y
avait un nouveau monde nouvelles façons
de faire de la politique etc
j'ai l'impression de retrouver les mêmes
rigidité que je trouvais dans les
majorités socialistes et parfois dans
les majorités de droite vous fait pour
moi j'ai su du maquereau nisme oui parce
que je pense que le parlement n'est pas
un empêchement n'est pas un ennui comme
le pense monsieur macron ses
gouvernements successifs
c'est au contraire un enrichissement
c'est à dire la capacité quand les
ministres leur administration des idées
de lait confrontés à des réalités
différentes qui existent sur nos
territoires à travers les sénateurs et à
travers les députés parce qu'il ya une
chose qu'on semble oubliée et d'ailleurs
que même la population française oublie
trop souvent ceux qui nous regardent
nous verrons nous ne croiserons jamais
un ministre ne pourront pas discuter
avec lui par contre ils peuvent
rencontrer leur député
ils peuvent rencontrer leurs sénateurs
et nous on sert à ça à faire en sorte
que les ministres en vantant ils
n'entendent pas que leur administration
mise en temps des français ce pouvoir
s'en montrent incapables c'est ça ma
déception à écouter on va revenir là
dessus on repart courant tous les thèmes
forts de cette semaine au parlement une
semaine encore très mal
par la pandémie les oppositions défendre
l'ouverture des petits commerces contre
les grandes surfaces le gouvernement s'y
oppose pour limiter les déplacements
la prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire fait grincer des dents au
parlement à l'assemblée comme au sénat
on va vous refaire le film de la semaine
la diffusion d'image de policiers
pendant les opérations de maintien de
l'ordre au coeur d'une proposition doit
la république en marche un texte jugé
liberticide par ses opposants
et on commence par le premier thème de
cette semaine la fronde de certains élus
locaux contre la fermeture des petits
commerces
[Musique]
dans un communiqué publié le 31 octobre
vous avez vous jean christophe lagarde
invité les élus du parti à prendre un
arrêté autorisant l'ouverture des
commerces de proximité douze maires de
seine-saint-denis ont d'ailleurs saisi
le conseil d'état pour demander la
suspension du décret fixant la liste des
commerces dits non essentiels alors
cette défense des petits commerçants que
vous avez réitéré cette semaine lors des
questions au gouvernement vous a valu
une remarque assez cinglante du premier
ministre on écoute jean castex vous
réagissez juste après quand la
république est confronté à la plus grave
crise sanitaire qu'elle ait subie depuis
des décennies on n'appelle pas les mères
serviteur de la république a violé les
lois de la république
ça n'est pas possible jean christophe
lagarde
est-ce que c'est pas une faute en tant
que responsables politiques d'appeler
finalement à la désobéissance
je ne crois pas je vais vous dire
pourquoi
d'abord la france elle n'est pas
confronté qu'à une crise sanitaire
elle est confrontée à un gouvernement
qui prend des mesures incohérentes qui
sont à la fois inefficace sur le plan
sanitaire et destructrice sur le plan
économique
et moi je suis un responsable politique
de l'opposition et je combats des
mesures qui sont absurdes
est ce que quelqu'un en france peut
croire qu en allant chez votre marchand
de chaussures ou chez votre marchand de
vêtements
vous avez plus de risque d'être
contaminé que quand vous allez dans
votre supermarché évidemment non
d'autant plus que au mois de mars ça se
comprenait on n'avait pas de masque on
avait pas de gel n'avait rien
aujourd'hui on est parfaitement protégé
est-ce qu'on peut m'expliquer dans le
décret du gouvernement pourquoi les
écoutez moi bien article 37
les marchands de tissus sont autorisés à
ouvrir et un marchand de tissus c'est
quelqu'un qui vend du tissu brut qui
vend des tapis ou qui vend du matériel
de tricot c'est ça la norme par contre
le maroc le magasin de prêt-à-porter le
magasin de vêtements lui peut pas
oublier une incohérence mais l'idée
c'est quand même de bien et bien lisser
les déplacés et bien d'abord merci de
reconnaître que c'est une incohérence et
nous ne sommes pas confrontés qu'à la
crise mais aussi à l'incohérence du
gouvernement deuxième point je veux bien
sûr qu'il faut limiter les déplacements
mais pardon de le dire c'est pas en
fermant une partie des commerces qu'on
limite les déplacements qu'est ce qui se
passe en france aujourd'hui les écoles
des collèges
les lycées sont ouverts les entreprises
de bâtiment sont sur les chantiers les
usines sont ouvertes les bureaux quand
on ne peut pas travailler de la même
façon les services publics sont ouverts
mais ça c'est une bonne chose je le dis
bien à vis de la crise a dit fax son ami
qui pourrait se séparer en soi une
mauvaise chose
les deux seules choses qui sont fermées
en france ce sont les universités et les
commerces de proximité et on prétend
limiter les déplacements avec ça mais
tous ceux qui nous regardent et qui
toute la journée voit que tout le monde
se déplace normalement se rendent bien
compte qu'en réalité ce n'est pas un
confinement
c'est une limitation de nos déplacements
et donc et je vais vous prendre un
exemple très simple très compréhensible
si on vous dit en dehors de vos heures
de travail vous n'avez le droit de
sortir qu'une heure par jour
laissons aux français le choix d'aller
chez le commerçant du coin ou au
supermarché ça ne change rien au
contraire je pense même qu'il est plus
en sécurité dans un petit côté pile
c'est inefficace sanitairement et c'est
destructeur économiquement jeu
christophe gaussin commerçants la
représente 3 à 4 millions d'emplois
minimum dans d'autres pays une fois
qu'ils seront morts on fera quoi est ce
que vous n'avez pas l'impression tout de
même que ce débat sur les commerces de
proximité et va pas devenir inaudible si
les hôpitaux sont saturés
d'ici quelques jours est ce que en
disant tout cela vous n'avez pas
l'impression de manquer d'anticipation
comme lorsqu'il y en a eu qui ont plaidé
pour la réouverture des bars et des
restaurants on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
c'est quelque chose de complètement un
peu si mme bardon mais le ceux qui ont
manqué d'anticipation sont ceux qui nous
gouvernent madame quant au mois de
juillet ils ont levé l'état d'urgence
sanitaire moi je disais qu'il fallait
pas levé parce que c'est un mauvais
signal envoyé aux français et tout le
monde a cru cet été que c'était la
libération
quant à la rentrée dernière ils ont
tardé parce qu'ils attendent que les
gens se rendent compte de la gravité de
la situation hors en attendent un
gouvernement justement d'anticiper ils
ont tardé à mettre en place des
couvre-feux ils ont reculé devant la
fronde de kate tel ou tel élu local
alors que la situation de sanitaires par
exemple dans les bouches-du-rhône
devenait catastrophique
le confinement lui-même arrive trop tard
et ce n'est pas un confinement puisque
aujourd'hui je répète les deux seules
choses fermés dans notre pays ce sont
les universités et les commerces de
proximité qu'est ce que vous êtes je
mens je sens que je pense du poujadisme
de faire du populisme c'est ce qu'estime
aujourd'hui à la majorité présidentielle
écoutez si les centristes sont devenus
des boues jadis c'était une nouveauté
politique qui méritera d'être inscrite
dans les héros de l'histoire
arrêtons les bêtises
d'accord nous nous sommes des gens
raisonnables responsables mais là encore
ce que je disais sur l'incapacité de
discussion avec ce gouvernement mais pas
que pour nous pour tout le monde il ne
discute avec personne ni avec colère là
jean christophe lagarde elle peut créer
un nouveau mouvement des gels et jouer
je pense qu'en plus ils prennent ce
risque là ils sont inefficaces année
salies terme en destructeur
économiquement et dangereux
politiquement
j'ai expliqué et je suis convaincu de sa
au gouvernement lors des questions
d'actualité j'ai commencé comme ça si
vous voulez que nous arrivions à
combattre ensemble le coc vide il ya
besoin que les français acceptent et
combattent c'est à dire soit raisonnable
et responsable même mais pour ça il faut
comprendre la mesure
comment vous expliquez que vous avez le
droit de passer le permis de conduire
mais vous ne pouvez plus prendre les
devants correspondante
comment vous expliquer ce que
j'expliquais sur le tissu quand c'est
incompréhensible
plus personne ne respecte ou en tout cas
pas suffisamment
donc ce n'est pas moi qui en disant ça
et sur l'appel au maire c'était
simplement d'essayer de retrouver la
logique qui est celle de l'efficacité en
violant les lois de la république c'est
quand même ce que vous dit jean castex
pardon c'est ce qu'il prétend
parce que c'est du juge administratif
qui décide si ça viole le les lois de la
république et certainement pas le
premier ministre mais pour revenir à ça
qu'est ce qu'il a dit quand il est
arrivé
moi je suis un homme de concertation et
territoires que demande le sénat nous
demandons nous à l'assemblée nationale
pour toutes les oppositions laisser les
préfets et les maires vous adapté parce
que la situation sanitaire n'est pas la
même aujourd'hui un nouvel aquitaine ou
drogué ça reste encadré c'est le préfet
préfet et maire on nous a vendu le
couple maires préfets au printemps voilà
qu'il a disparu et que tout part de
paris tout et partout pareil est ce
qu'on a besoin à paimpol de la même
règle qu'à lyon je ne le crois pas voilà
deux pourquoi je me bats je ne comprends
pas que ce gouvernement qui parle sans
arrêt de concertation qui parlait du
coup hop le maire préfet en réalité à
oublier tout ça jeter à la poubelle et
pardon ce n'est pas de la responsabilité
de jean christophe lagarde ou de
n'importe quel autre élu de l'opposition
si la courbe ils nous l'ont déjà annoncé
mais ne vient pas très loin il est
partout non ce n'est pas vrai il n'est
pas partout de la même façon moi je
constate je consulte les statistiques
données par le gouvernement sur santis
public france il ya des zones qui sont
moins circuler je vous prends un dernier
exemple d'incohérences
heureusement cette fois ci ils n'ont pas
fermé les marchés mais vous avez le
droit pour les commerçants alimentaires
et pas pour les autres
vous avez le sentiment que quand vous
êtes dans un marché à l'air libre ou en
réalité il ya aucun risque de
contamination
vous n'êtes plus en danger si elle est
commerçant dans l'alimentaire que s'il
ya seulement des animations c'est
absurde c'est absurde d'une phrase c'est
cette absurdité qui fait que nous sommes
inefficace par rapport à l'allemagne
pardon mais en allemagne à 80 millions
d'habitants en france 70 on a 35 mille
morts et qui sont à dix mille on a
cinquante mille cas par jour ils sont à
10000 e discute localement et adaptent
leur situation du coup la population
comprend du coup elle est plus
respectueuse des mesures qui sont
nécessaires
allez on va continuer par l'esa
puisqu'on passe au deuxième thème de
l'émission
l'état d'urgence sanitaire un véritable
feuilleton au parlement
[Musique]
alors les débats sur l'état d'urgence
sanitaire ont été houleux cette semaine
à l'assemblée les oppositions ont réussi
à battre momentanément la majorité pour
réduire la période de l'état d'urgence
qui a provoqué la colère du ministre de
la santé olivier véran les précisions
dels monts à gabes à 21h mardi soir les
députés examinent le texte sur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire débat sur sa date de
fin le gouvernement propose le 16
février 2021
les oppositions veulent qu'une clause de
revoyure avant les fêtes de fin d'année
les républicains au ppte pour le 14
décembre qui est pour lever le doigt
et à la surprise générale qui est contre
et se structure
il est adopté si les oppositions ont
fait le plein dans leurs ronds les bancs
de la majorité sont plus clairsemés
malgré des suspensions de séance pour
tenter de rappeler ses troupes
la majorité est battu une seconde fois
un amendement impose aux gouvernements
l'aval du parlement pour confiner au
delà du 30 novembre
les oppositions jubile de quoi mettre
hors de lui un ministre de la santé de
retour d'une visite à l'hôpital de
corbeil essonnes dans la première
chambre il avait un jeune homme de 28
ans de 28 ans en coma intubé et ventilé
dans la deuxième chambre
il y avait un homme en surpoids âgé de
35 ans c'est ça la réalité mesdames et
messieurs merritt est celle où les
valentin sorte invités elle est là la
réalité de capitaux une invective qui ne
passe pas chez les oppositions le
ministre vos propos étaient indignes et
vous avez été un 10 c'est insupportable
monsieur le ministre le chantage que
vous êtes en train de nous faire tout le
monde ici a conscience de la gravité de
la situation vous n'avez certainement
pas le monopole de vouloir la santé des
français de vouloir leur sécurité
sanitaire le lendemain le gouvernement
procède à une nouvelle délibération qui
lui permet de revenir au texte initial
christophe lagarde qu'est-ce que vous
avez pensez vous des propos d'olivier
ferrand vous et moi je peux comprendre
que le musée la santé soit fatigué il a
un rôle qui est compliqué en ce moment
comme le pr vénisse qui disait un peu
n'importe quoi en réponse aux aux
questions d'actualité ce que je ne peux
pas admettre d'abord c'est qu'un
ministre vienne dans l'enceinte de
l'assemblée nationale ou du sénat dire
aux élus auxquels il est censé rendre
compte de ses actes je ne peux pas
accepter l'idée qu'il vienne nous dire
si vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec moi
sortez d'ici dans quel régime est-on
voulait demander de s'excuser pour ses
mots il aurait dit s'il aurait
clairement dû le faire et il devrait le
faire parce qu'il a perdu toute capacité
de dialoguer au moins avec les
oppositions alors la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale elle doit elle est
le doigt sur la couture de sur la
couture du pantalon
donc il peut s'en servir autant qu'il
veut il peut même leur marcher dessus
idées ont rien mais pardon mais est ce
qu'on peut faire de la politique sur un
sujet qui est aussi sérieux que la crise
sanitaire on a bien vu à l'assemblée
nationale ce qu'on appelle le coup du
rideau
beaucoup de députés d'opposition qui
sont à réussir
pas vrai mais ce n'est pas vrai c'est un
mensonge car vous aviez un reportage
dans le petit journal hier qui m'ont
très bien il n'y a jamais eu ça il se
trouve que les autres étaient là les et
les nerfs les communistes les
socialistes nous mêmes à lui dit et que
la reine n'était pas là c'est pas le
coup dur il a eu un mot d'ordre des
oblats selon un journaliste j'étais dans
l'hémicycle nous nous sommes retrouvés
surpris de cette situation mais on
n'allait quand même pas sortir parce que
les députés la république en marche
faisait pas leur boulot
faut quand même arrêter et quand vous
dites faire de la politique non je
dénonce ça absolument
on ne fait pas lourd de la politique on
est tous conscients de la gravité de la
situation et nous sommes malheureux de
voir un gouvernement
incohérent et parfois inconséquent et
s'il avait conscience de ce qu'est la
démocratie et s'il se rendait compte que
ensemble nous serions plus forts que
quand il veut être seul et décider de
tout comme le dit monsieur virant ceux
qui ne sont pas d'accord avec moi sortez
d'ici
et bien c'est comme ça qu'il affaiblit
la capacité de combat
personne n'a fait de politique
politicienne la turquie ce qui était
demandé dans cet amendement vous savez
ce qui était demandé dans cette affaire
on va parler du fond puisque en effet un
retour à la case départ pour ce texte
qui prévoit d'instaurer l'état d'urgence
sanitaire jusqu'à mi-février au sénat
aussi les parlementaires ont été agacés
que le gouvernement reste campé sur un
état d'urgence de trois mois au point
même de se demander s'il était bien
utile de travailler sur ce texte
mais le ton est resté beaucoup plus
calme dans l'hémicycle pierre-henri
holderbaum lors du vote de la
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
la série heroes brise le président de la
commission des lois a ouvert la séance
avec une mise au point
nous entendons depuis quelques heures
une moindre mesure depuis quelques jours
une sorte de procès en irresponsabilité
à l'encontre du sénat voire en démagogie
alors que nous avons donné je le crois
monsieur le ministre au gouvernement
tous les moyens qui était utile pour
combattre le fléau épidémique
le secrétaire d'état chargé de l'enfance
et des familles
aurélien taquet a essayé de calmer les
tensions entre la haute assemblée et le
gouvernement mais il est
convergence quelque chose sur lequel
nous sommes d'accord monsieur le
président c'est l'exigence du contrôle
parlementaire pour reprendre les termes
mêmes de votre rapporteur il ya quelques
jours dans la presse et reconnaît
certains points de divergence entre la
chambre haute et le gouvernement le
sénat a répondu et s'est montré
intraitable
nous n'avons jamais dit que nous ne
voulions pas que le confinement se
prolonge au delà du vix décembre nous
avons seulement dit que s'il devait se
prolonger au delà de 8 décembre il
faudrait que le parlement l'autorisent
nous n'avons pas dit non plus que nous
ne voulions pas que l'état d'urgence se
prolonge au delà du 31 janvier
nous avons seulement dit que s'il devait
se prolonger au delà du 31 janvier
il faudrait que le parlement le vote le
ministre a toutefois essayé de proposer
une nouvelle fois la prolongation d'un
régime transitoire au 1er avril
le sénat a rejeté la demande la séance
est levée le texte de loi repart à
l'assemblée nationale où les députés ont
le dernier mot
bon finalement jean christophe lagarde
comme le souhaitait le gouvernement
l'état d'urgence il va courir jusqu'à
mi-février
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que le
parlement sert encore à quelque chose
dans l'esprit du gouvernement il ne sert
à rien le problème comme je vous le dis
c'est qu'à force de n'écouter personne
il perdre la crédibilité l'attention des
français comme je le disais qu'est ce
qu'il y avait dans l'amendement voté à
l'assemblée nationale c'était simplement
le fait que l'état d'urgence on allait
en fait revenir tous les deux mois comme
on l'a fait en mars
edouard philippe il avait demandé deux
mois puis on a eu un nouveau débat on
l'a plongée personne ne conteste la
nécessité de l'état d'urgence je viens
de vous dire que moi au mois de juillet
je voulais pas qu'il soit levé mais les
absences en jambes elle par l'homme et
des avocats êtes la glace est bien sûr
non seulement il en jambes mais il
écrase en réalité ce qu'il ne supporte
pas c'est qu'il puisse y avoir un débat
sur ce qu'il décide c'est exactement ce
qu'on a connu pardon avant les gilet
jaune
1 vous vous souvenez le pouvoir
jupitérien est de retour dans cette
circonstance je ne suis pas sûr je ne
suis pas sûr que ce soit la du président
de la république accessoirement mais le
pouvoir jupitérien est de retour et donc
ça veut dire que tout ce qu'ils disent
sous prétexte que nous sommes dans une
crise sanitaire n'est plus contestable
je vous ai donné des exemples
d'absurdité que les français nommait les
jours ont tenu de la crise sanitaire
vous pensez pas que le 14 décembre c'est
un petit peu tôt pour lever cet état
d'urgence end là on est aussi
ce fait briller les mi décembre si c'est
quand même est-ce que vous pouvez tomber
parce que vous me laissez vos réponses
soyons sérieux
si l'amendement a été adopté au 14
décembre c'est parce que c'était le
premier de la liste le plus éloigné du
texte ce que souhaitait en réalité la
majorité des opposants
c'était de dire qu'on se retrouve le 15
janvier d'accord or c'est à dire
réadapter le délai qui avait choisi
edouard philippe
pourquoi qu'est ce que c'est que l'état
d'urgence sanitaire c'est une boîte à
outils que le gouvernement peut utiliser
il prend les outils nécessaires on lui
confie quasiment les pleins pouvoirs
c'est ça ce que ça veut dire pour
restreindre les libertés publiques votre
liberté de vous déplacer votre liberté
travail et l'autre bref et il est normal
qu'ils rendent des comptes au parlement
dans ce dans ce contexte là vous dites
avec cette date du ccs est attentatoire
aux libertés
c'est parfaitement inutile est ce que le
gouvernement a le moindre risque que le
parlement refuse la prolongation de
l'état d'urgence la majorité d'une
docilité tels que toute façon donc ce
qu'il veut éviter c'est pas qu'on n'ait
un état d'urgence
insuffisamment long je pense qu'il ira
bien au delà du 14 février ce qu'il veut
éviter c'est qu'on puisse débattre de
l'efficacité de ces mesures
je répète quand même d'exemple que j'ai
pris c'est ce que j'ai dit à monsieur
véran l'assemblée nationale si vous
étiez ministre de la santé allemand
monsieur vous donneriez des leçons mais
enfin vous avez quatre fois et demi plus
de morts qu'en allemagne
vous avez cinq fois plus de
contaminations en allemagne 1 sont en
train de re confiné on n'est pas
tellement de l'allemagne continue comme
les autres à le manier confiné
l'allemagne est confiné à dire il cas
par jour
quand on était à dix mille cas par jour
qu'est ce qu'on nous disait partez en
vacances quand on est à dix mille cas
par jour en allemagne
on nous dit attention au court à la
catastrophe on restreint et ils sont pas
obligés d'aller au confinement
on peut quand même accepter de regarder
ce qui est le plus efficace c'est pas
faire vous auriez fait quoi vous si vous
étiez à la place du gouvernement
alors d'abord je pense que dans la
situation au moment où ils ont décidé de
confinement fallait faire un vrai
confinement pendant quinze jours et ce
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
pendant un mois ensuite parce qu'il
fallait donner un coup d'arrêt brutal
tous les français au dauphiné totalement
la populaire je pense qu'on avait besoin
d'un confinement brutal pour gars que
vous défendez l'ouverture des petits
commerces
ça peut être incohérent aussi non non
c'est pas incohérent simplement il faut
du temps pour l'expliquer quand vous
laissez tout ouvert et que la seule
chose que vous fermez c'est les
commerces vous ne combattez pas la
maladie vous tuer juste des commerçants
quand vous avez une situation sanitaire
où il nous explique que dans dix jours
nos hôpitaux vont exploser et qu'on ne
sera plus capable d'accepter les gens en
réanimation et qu'on sera obligé de
faire un tri parce que c'est ça la
réalité entre ce qu'ils pourront avoir
une chance de survivre est ce qu'ils
seront condamnés à mourir comme à
bergame en italie au printemps dernier
je pense qu'à ce moment là il fallait
donner un vrai coup de frein avec un
confinement de quinze jours qui permet
rapidement de faire baisser la
contamination et de rouvrir
progressivement un peu dans la situation
dans laquelle nous nous trouvons
aujourd'hui je pense que s'ils ont à
chaque fois en fait ce que fait ce
gouvernement c'est qu'ils courent
derrière l'épidémie il court derrière la
crise il ne l'anticipent jamais une
dernière question dans l'actualité est
ce qu il faut instaurer pour vous une
amende pour ceux qui ne respectent pas
la quarantaine notamment lorsqu'ils sont
quatre contacter les députés de la
majorité veulent une amende de 10000
euros
d'abord avant que l'avant de mettre une
amende il faudrait qu'on soit en
capacité de le surveiller
parce que ça c'est des trucs qu'on fait
pour se faire plaisir à la télévision et
puis pour dire vous voyez on est
vraiment très dur très sérieux favorable
aujourd'hui les cas contacts ils sont
surveillés comment madame avant de
mettre une amende pouvez toujours
inventer des peines pouvaient même leur
mettre dix ans de prison qui surveille
les cas la contacter est ce que par
exemple une application fait qu'on
détecte à l'endroit où vous êtes est ce
que il ya un contrôle
ça a été les charges et authentique au
vide oui il est là je suis désolé pour
le premier unis j'ai pas besoin de
m'énerver et d'ailleurs gelé déclenchée
avant de rentrer ici puisque pour vous
comme pour moi c'est plus c'est plus sûr
et je recommande à tout le monde de le
faire et je trouve en plus que cette
application est maintenant vraiment bien
fait
ce qui n'était pas le cas au printemps
donc je dis simplement que on manque de
sérieux de construction de consensus par
dans la construction du consensus et le
rôle du gouvernement et de la majorité
c'est pas les oppositions qui peuvent le
faire à leur place
et du coup on manque d'efficacité aussi
bien sur le plan sanitaire et on paiera
très cher sur le plan économique les
erreurs qui sont en train d'être fait
allez on va terminer cette émission en
changeant de sujet c'est le plus de la
semaine
[Musique]
à l'assemblée une proposition de loi sur
la sécurité a été adoptée en commission
elle sera débattue le 17 novembre dans
l'hémicycle elle vise à mieux coordonner
et police et gendarmerie mais aussi la
sécurité privée
elle encadre la vente d'équipements
pyrotechnique change les règles
d'utilisation des caméras mobiles pour
les agents de la force publique
et puis elle limite aussi la diffusion
d'image des forces de l'ordre sur le
terrain ce qui suscite la controverse
une proposition largement défendue par
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin on écoute je remercie les
parlementaires de mettre en oeuvre la
promesse que j'ai faite aux forces de
sécurité ne pas être jetés en pâture sur
les réseaux sociaux
rappelez-vous le drame de magnanville on
ne sait pas si ce sont les images et
réseaux sociaux qui ont fait naître ou
pas cet attentat mais enfin un policier
assassiné une policière qui travaillent
dans les services techniques de la
police assassiné parce que policiers en
civil chez eux en dehors de leur lieu de
travail
c'est vraiment jeté devant leurs enfants
égorgés devant leurs enfants c'est
vraiment jeté en pâture des
fonctionnaires qui font un travail
extrêmement difficile et au temps j'ai
dit aux policiers que je ne souhaitais
pas qu'il soit cagoulés dans les
manifestations parce que la police de la
république et à visage découvert
sauf exceptions notamment antiterroriste
par exemple bien sûr autant nous leur
devons protection lorsqu'ils sont jetés
en europe dans les réseaux sociaux parce
que vous connaissez tous des policiers
ou des gendarmes qui sont insultés quand
ils ont supermarché avec leurs enfants
ou leur femme ou avec leurs maris
lorsqu'ils sont au club de sport du coin
une lourdement protection et nos jours
merci de mettre en place ce foot alger
bits
est ce que vous êtes favorable à ce
texte jean christophe lagarde je
souhaiterais même qu'ils soient
renforcés sur un certain nombre de
problèmes d'ailleurs c'est parce que je
vous dise et annoncé qu'ils courent
toujours derrière les événements
pourquoi on renforce la sécurité des
policiers c'est parce que des policiers
ont été agressés c'est pas nouveau
bon et tant mieux si ça se fait comme je
dis moi je suis dans l'opposition mais
de façon constructive
il ya des choses aussi dans la vie
quotidienne des gens comme les squats de
halls d'immeubles comme les motos
immatriculées qui sont dangereuses et
que la police n'arrête plus c'est que je
souhaiterais aussi voir venir c'est ça
la sécurité globale
c'est prendre en compte l'état va mal
pour nous mais je la voterai quand il ya
des choses à ajouter je la voterai en
fonction du débat excusez moi je veux
quand même voir ce qu'il y aura dedans
parce que le texte qui va nous être
présentés c'est déjà plus le texte qu'il
dédia quinze jours donc je préfère
toujours attendre
la fin mais j'ai un a priori favorable
et y compris sur le point que vous
soulevez concernant le flottage d'autant
plus que j'ai fait cette proposition il
ya deux ans ou trois ans je frémis pas
que ça la restreignent la liberté
d'information a traversé faut pas
raconter de bobards
voilà ce que devrait être à mon avis le
point d'équilibré vous avez parfaitement
le droit aux journalistes citoyens de
filmer une intervention de police qui
peut servir pour la justice de preuves
si jamais un policier faute très bien
mais par contre vous ne devez pas avoir
le droit de diffuser sur les réseaux
sociaux sans flouter l'image de la
personne parce que quand vous voulez
prendre une image pour prouver la
justice vous êtes un bon citoyen quand
vous diffusez pour que en réalité on
reconnaisse l'individu vous changé de
nature
d'accord et vous mettez en danger un
policier qui par ailleurs n'a peut-être
pas commis de faute parce que je vous
ferai remarquer que la plupart du temps
ce qu'on a comme l'image c'est un tout
peu toute petite partie de
l'intervention donc filmé ne me pose
aucun problème
diffusée sans floutage c'est mettre en
danger les forces de sécurité c'est même
une force de chantage si vous discutez
avec des policiers assez souvent
vous avez des gens qui leur disent ah
tiens on va vous filmer comme ça vous ne
pouvez pas le déversement a dit que
cette profession loi pour des risques
considérables pour les droits des biens
d'un manteau et bien mes lecteurs eh
bien le défenseur des droits va laisser
le parlement faire son travail parce que
c'est au parlement d'en décider
et deuxièmement je vais vous dire j'ai
une deuxième proposition c'est que tous
les policiers devraient avoir sur une
caméra qu'on appelle une caméra piétons
et qui la déclenche à chaque
intervention qu'ils font sur un citoyen
ce qui est prévu c'est d'abord oui mais
ça fait trois quatre ans que je demande
ça ce qui est d'abord comment dh
protecteur de la personne en face des
fois qu'il ya un débordement est
vraiment mais c'est aussi un excellent
extrêmement dissuasif parce que vous
avez vous avez des tas de gens qui se
comportent mal vis-à-vis des policiers
lors d'un contrôle quelconque et qui
ensuite viens de vous raconter que c'est
le policier
du coup on vend nos forces de l'ordre
incapable de faire les choses si vous
avez une caméra piétons qui filme la
scène que ce soit le contrevenant
éventuels ou le policier tout le monde
est obligé de se respecter et à ce
moment là on sait ce qui s'est passé la
fin de cette émission merci et jean
christophe lagarde
merci à thème traduit merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivi rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
parlement hebdo
[Musique]